welcome back to CBS this morning we got
a full table we're gonna get right to it
the fight against teen vaping and
flavored cigarettes just got a 160
million dollar boost Bloomberg
philanthropies revealed this morning
that its funding a new program aimed at
ending the epidemic the campaign for
tobacco-free kids will coordinate the
push this follows a new study that found
flavor was the reason most young adults
said they started using e-cigarettes
first on CBS this morning Bloomberg LP
and Bloomberg philanthropies founder
Michael Bloomberg and the president of
the campaign for tobacco-free kids
Matthew Myers join us gentlemen good
morning morning what a frightening mess
we find ourselves in when it comes to
e-cigarettes all the progress we've made
in reducing teen smoking in particular
is being turned around because the kids
like the flavor in the vaping products
and they they're not people giving up
smoking they're not people that ever
smoked before this is a whole new group
that's getting themselves addicted to
nicotine and in one pod that you use in
a vaping innovate it's the equivalent of
all the nicotine in a whole pack of
cigarettes you call this in and up at an
urgent health crisis and say tobacco
companies are behind it oh there's no
question about that they're advertising
to kids they run these enormous ads
every day in the paper saying we'll help
you stop smoking but they've never
released any evidence whatsoever that it
does anything to help you stop smoking
in fact most people that vape never
smoked before well the the timeline for
them to reveal that evidence would be
20/20 when the FDA has a deadline four
kids are dying people are dying now and
getting addictive timelines yesterday
not tomorrow mine was before they put it
on the marketplace
they shouldn't be experimenting with the
entire American public what we know is
these products are addicting millions of
kids and we have no scientific evidence
submitted to the FDA whatsoever that
they're actually effective in helping
smokers quit blame the FDA the FDA has a
role it was too slow to regulate and
once it began to regulate it pushed off
the deadline at FDA kept the deadline
for submitting product review we would
know much more about what's in these
products and we'd know whether the
flavors I add not only help but dick
kids but may be the cause of some of the
problems were seeing I would
yes is the answer to your question you
don't let them well you don't let the
public do something one the science says
it's probably bad for you and you're in
the middle of conducting research wait
until you do the research if it's fine
no problem no harm no foul I'm curious
why you say that the science says it's
probably bad for you because one of the
more perplexing things about this whole
issue is public health England
England's version of the CDC they say
that e-cigarettes are 95 to 98 percent
safer than traditional cigarettes yeah
well so does Wilbur Ross so come on I
mean let's get serious
okay well it's bad science but the most
important thing to understand is in this
country we have 3.6 million kids who are
using these products over a quarter of
them are addicted
most of them would never have used any
tobacco product we know that heavy doses
of nicotine for those young people
increases their risk of disease
increases the risk of smoking in the
future and it has a long-term harmful
effect on their developing brain so this
isn't a question of that sort of
comparison what we know is for our young
people who would never have use any
product this product design just think
if your kid was doing this and winds up
with an IQ 10 or 15 points lower than he
or she would have had for the rest of
her life that demonstrated this is the
science shows that it has a negative
impact on brain development it's hard to
measure those kinds of things what we do
know is there's no question young people
are highly sensitive to nicotine it
makes it more likely that they'll suffer
lifelong addictions and it makes it more
likely that they'll go on to smoke
cigarettes we had seen cigarette smoking
among our kids plummet to all-time low
until jul was introduced it reversed
what over the last three years we've
made for the first time in a very long
time we've made no progress in reducing
cigarette smoking but it hasn't gone off
it hasn't gone up but the decline has
stopped and the number of kids who are
using nicotine based products it's
higher than it is than it has been at
any time since 2004 so that's a problem
at and mr. mayor how do you intend to
spend the money and what will be your
definition of swell campaigns you got to
explain to people what's going on
you know what the mistake we make in
government all the time is to tell
people what to do that doesn't work you
have to explain to people why it is in
their interest to do something like not
run the risk even if you don't believe
that it's gonna happen there's no reason
to run a risk that can damage your
health for the rest of your life until
the science is complete and I find it
absolutely inconceivable that the state
governments are pushing both with this
and other products that are addictive
people to go and use it now and then
we'll worry about it later your goal is
to ban all flavored cigarettes and you
think you can cut usage by a third and
these targeted area all of the evidence
shows that the kids like the flavors
that's the reason they do it when you
talk to them they don't smoke the
products that don't have the flavors you
know if you eliminate mint in mango you
can pretty well should be sure that
you're going to see a dramatic decline
in youth use of these products and if we
can do that it's a very first and
important step and it has become even
more urgent with all the recent evidence
that shows that some people are
suffering very severe respiratory
diseases we don't know what's causing it
but we do know that if we dramatically
cut the number of kids who start we
reduce and the papers editorial trade
commission says stop all these
advertisements mr. mayor time is running
out we can't let you leave without
hearing getting your take on the
political climate today you know
anything going on at one point you would
considered running we know that you
decided not to do that
anybody who has caught your I know it's
very early on I know people are still
making their cases but who are you
anybody that you're looking at thinking
I like what they're saying well I'll
look at it down the road at the moment
my job is to stay out of it and let
campaign people that want to run but
which I decided not to express
themselves and tell what things they
would do if they got elected
I think it's any cigarette Joe Biden's
been a friend of mine for many many
years played golf together did a lot of
things together when he was vice
president but I'll see there are some
attractive candidates are you sitting
here going I wish I had done it no I
never think back there was not a road
from me when Joe was in the race to get
through because we would have split the
votes and just why not
stand up and say no Matt Matt you were
telling me in the green room under mr.
under Mike Bloomberg's tenure what
happened to life expectancy in this say
you want an example of somebody who
makes a difference when he was the mayor
of New York life expectancy in New York
City rose actually over three years I'll
take it became longer than throughout
the rest of the country
so if you want to know what happens when
you encourage good health practices and
protect your citizens you can make a
difference and if you love somebody get
them to move to New York and they were
[Laughter]
serious on average can't guarantee
anyone but on average they will live
better
unfortunately expensive as Galen I would
try to early as you do about real estate
life expectancy in the United States has
gone down three years in a row it's the
first time since World War one a lot of
drugs a lot of reasons why now mr. mayor
if you could just do something about
housing prices it cost to arms or legs
and a spleen to live in the city that we
all love so much but we got to go
Michael Bloomberg and Matthew Myers a